Let's talk about one of the most famous
Mathematical theories
Pythagorean theory
It is about the triangles of the corner menu.
So, the triangle-based corner is the one that includes
90 degree angle
So the way I drew it here
This is a 90 degree angle
If you have not seen an angle before
He thought if this side ran from the left
To the right, the last extends from top to bottom
They are perpendicular, meaning that the corner is confined
Between them is equal to 90 degrees "angle list".
The Pythagorean theory tells us that if we deal
With an existing triangle - let me write this - if we are
We deal with an existing triangle - not right - right or right.
If we are dealing with an existing triangle
It is a triangle with a 90-degree angle
Therefore, the relationship between its aspects is this.
So, this aspect is A and B and this is T.
Remember that the side we are dealing with here
Is the opposite side of the angle measuring 90 degrees.
It is important to note what each side is.
Pythagorean theory tells us that if and only if
There was a square triangle with a quadrilateral square
Equal squared.
And to use this information.
Knowing two of the three sides we can use
This equation to find the third side.
I will tell you another term here
This long side, the longest aspect
Triangle-based, and corresponding to the existing angle
This is here - in the example -
Call it chord.
Tendon
The name is very luxurious
The longest side of the triangle is the opposite
The 90-degree angle is called the tendon.
Now that we know the theory of Pythagoras
Let us use it.
Because knowledge is good, but
The pleasure is to use it.
So let us say that I have the following triangle
Let me paint one more confident than this.
This is a triangle
This aspect here is 9.
This aspect length is 7.
My question is, how long is this aspect here?
Maybe we can call this t.
Well, v here, again, is the chord.
It's the tallest side.
So we know that the total squares of the other two sides
Equal to the T box
So using Pythagorean theorem 9 squared + 7 squared
= Squaring
Squared = 81 + 7 Squared =
80 + 40 = 120
Then 1 + 9 these 10 other
Total 130 (120 + 10)
So write it this way.
The total left side is equal to 130 and this is equal to
Square T.
So how much do you compare?
Let me rewrite here.
Square V equals 130 or we can say that
The square root is equal to 130
Note, I have taken into account the main root
Only because it must be positive.
We are dealing with distance and therefore we can not take negative
So we will take into consideration
Only the positive root
And to facilitate this we know how
Simplify roots.
130 is 2 hit 65 equals 5 hit 13
So, these are all prime numbers,
This is easy to find
V equals root 130.
Let us have one of these